tv le 2 décembre au lieu aujourd'hui
centenaire c'est pas la première fois on
a refait aux stadistes plusieurs fois
mais là c'était le bicentenaire et nous
étions par -10° et 20 centimètres de
neige
jean-michel petit reconstitue les
batailles napoléoniennes c'est sa
passion
féru d'histoire il a grâce à cela
voyager à travers le monde avec plus ou
moins de facilité pour faire passer les
armes pour aller aux états unis il a dû
se munir de ce carnet mais dit-il malgré
les contraintes et les consignes la
reconstitution est un véritable
patrimoine historique
la reconstitution cette histoire vivante
ça permet c'est beaucoup mieux qu'à
l'histoire vous avez vous hâte des
gamins devant un bivouac de
reconstitutions de batailles je vous
lirai voit tout de suite il voit autre
chose et ça leur parle davantage du
moyen âge ou de guerre la reconstitution
rassemble des passionnés qui n'hésitent
pas qui a retapé vieux véhicules
d'autres des canons des uniformes ou
bien d'autres choses pour recréer
l'atmosphère de l'époque ça représente
en france je pense au moins au moins 700
personnes
finalement absolument et ça existait à
l'extérieur dans toute l'europe avant
que ça existe en france cette loi votée
le 15 février dernier au sénat les
reconstitueurs en attendent avec crainte
les décrets d'application il réclame
donc une entrevue avec jacqueline
gourault la ministre auprès du ministre
de l'intérieur gérard collomb afin
d'exprimer leur point de vue